As we’ve discussed in detail before (see:
The Curious Case of the Claque), audiences
haven’t always been kind to performers throughout
history as evidenced by the fact that there
was a thriving industry of people who made
a rather lucrative living during the 19th
and early 20th centuries by simply booing
plays and operas unless the actors paid them
to stop.
But the question at hand is: Did audiences
ever go further than this and express their
dissatisfaction by pelting the performers
with rotten fruit as countless TV shows and
movies have depicted or is that simply a fictional
plot device?
Despite the idea of rotten tomatoes being
synonymous with a poor performance to such
an extent that one of the leading film review
websites in the world is named for it, audiences
throughout most of history have thrown pretty
much everything at performers but tomatoes.
For example, audience members in the cheap
seats at vaudevillian shows often liked to
chuck peanuts at performers, leading to the
creation of the term “peanut gallery”.
Going back significantly further in history,
rowdy and notoriously fickle Roman audiences
watching the gladiatorial games would sometimes
throw objects, though not necessarily food,
at gladiators if they displeased them.
Of course, audiences back then sometimes got
as good as they gave.
For example, Emperor Elagabalus was known
to have baskets full of deadly venomous snakes
thrown into crowds, sometimes to disperse
them, and sometimes just for his own general
amusement.
(He was notorious for such “practical jokes”.)
Long before this in AD 63, it was noted by
Suetonius that then governor of Africa and
later Emperor of Rome, Vespasian, governed
the region “with great justice and high
honour, save that in a riot at Hadrumetum
he was pelted with turnips”.
Fast-forwarding a bit through history, we
know it was a popular practise in Shakespearean
times to huck various food items at performers
at Shakespeare’s Globe Theatre during its
heyday.
But despite what is often stated, they almost
certainly wouldn’t have thrown tomatoes.
How can we be so sure?
Tomatoes are a “New World” item and they
weren’t commonly found in Britain until
the mid-18th century.
That said, they technically were introduced
to Europe around the 16th century, but tomatoes
were greeted with disdain and outright fear
– rumors even circulated that tomatoes were
poisonous.
(A similar thing happened with potatoes, with
this tuber not becoming widely popular until
some clever tricks and antics used by Frenchman
Antoine-Augustine Parmentier in which he managed
to convince the masses that potatoes were
just fine to eat.)
So while it’s technically possible that
a performer was hit with a tomato at this
point (the original Globe being built in 1599),
the odds of someone in the cheap seats of
a play here having one on hand, let alone
enough to pass around to ensure a performer
got hit, is highly unlikely and there is no
documented evidence of it, despite many claims
to the contrary.
Lacking tomatoes, a popular missile of choice
for overly critical audiences was eggs largely
due to them being easy to throw, cheap, smelly
(when rotten), hard to wipe off, and perhaps
most importantly, infinitely satisfying to
land a direct hit with.
It’s noted that audience members in the
pit at the Globe regularly hurled eggs at
actors if they got bored and as a result,
Shakespeare often tried to sandwich his more
serious scenes with either comedy (often of
a bawdy nature) or violence to placate those
in the cheap seats so that the show could
go on.
To find documented examples of audiences throwing
tomatoes at performers, you have to fast-forward
to the 19th century and travel to America
where the practise eventually became surprisingly
common.
American audiences of this period are noted
as being among the “rowdiest of all” and
it wasn’t uncommon for them to turn up to
performances carrying armfuls of potential
missiles (including tomatoes).
Much like rotten eggs, rotten tomatoes were
cheap in some regions and made for a conveniently
proportioned object to throw that also made
a very satisfactory splat when the target
was hit.
Beyond culinary items, American audiences
of the age were also known to go so far as
to tear up chairs and throw them at the performers
if they weren’t happy with the way the show
was going.
Even on an occasion where the crowd enjoyed
a performance, actors and singers of this
period still weren’t safe and they’d often
be required to “repeat a speech as many
times as the crowd demanded” or risk having
fruit, eggs, stones, and pretty much anything
that wasn’t nailed down thrown at them.
A particularly notable example of the former
(and the first known documented instance of
tomato lobbing at a show) occurred in 1883
when an acrobat called John Ritchie was forced
to flee from the stage.
The New York Times article covering the event
noted,
John Ritchie… made his debut before a Hempstead
audience at Washington Hall a few evenings
ago.
He had a crowded house, and was warmly received,
in fact, it was altogether too hot for him,
there being distributed among the audience
a bushel or two of rotten tomatoes.
The first act opened with Mr. Ritchie trying
to turn a somersault.
He probably would have succeeded had not a
great many tomatoes struck him, throwing him
off his balance and demoralizing him.
It was some time before the audience could
induce him to go on with the performance.
He next attempted to perform on the trapeze.
As he lay upon the bar with his face toward
the audience, a large tomato thrown from the
gallery struck him square between the eyes,
and he fell to the stage floor just as several
bad eggs dropped upon his head.
Then the tomatoes flew thick and fast, and
Ritchie fled for the stage door.
The door was locked, and he ran the gauntlet
for the ticket office through a perfect shower
of tomatoes.
He reached it, and the show was over.
This leads us to the obvious question of why
exactly did audiences feel the need to express
themselves so violently through most of history,
particularly when it would sometimes result
in the show they paid to see being canceled
and even an occasional riot?
Mob mentality obviously plays a large role
and it has already been clearly demonstrated,
both via anecdotal instances and controlled
experiments, that people’s behaviour in
a group can be strongly influenced by a few
bad eggs.
In fact, this was the major point of the Claque
in the first place.
Those on stage found that they could easily
control audience reactions by having a few
well paid individuals in the crowd set the
tone.
Humans being humans, the rest of the crowd
generally followed, regardless of the actual
quality of the show in question.
Beyond all this, the idea of a “passive
audience” is noted to be a fairly recent
phenomenon in theatre and throughout history
crowds have always been encouraged in some
way to express their enthusiasm, and even
sometimes take part in the show in some way,
starting way back in Ancient Greece where
audience participation in plays and speeches
was considered practically a civic duty.
The obvious downside of this is that crowds
also felt entitled to express their displeasure
in any way they pleased.
And while the quality of the show on the stage
may well have been improved by performers
not having to worry about things thrown at
them or an audience member running onto the
stage, because people were so willing to do
this sort of thing, a performer admonishing
the crowd for doing this would have been a
brave act indeed.
Beyond this, the audience themselves didn’t
mind as half the fun of going to these shows
was interacting with the performers in some
way for some (particularly in the cheap seats)
and for others observing what certain members
of the crowd would get up to during the show.
So how did we go from many hundreds of years
of audience participation in theatre to the
passive audiences we have today, less than
a century later?
To begin with, shows began shifting from the
actors actively acknowledging the audience
was there, generally purposefully interacting
with them, to instead pretending the audience
was non-existent and performing as though
what was happening on the stage was real and
sort of “in another dimension”, so to
speak.
Essentially, the invisible fourth wall was
created to preserve the illusion, and audiences
began to more and more be expected not to
break that wall down by interrupting the performance.
Other factors that helped this switch along
included advancements in stage lighting, allowing
for shifting the focus from both the audience
and the stage to just the stage, further solidifying
the invisible “fourth wall”.
Accordingly, theatres were redesigned and
rather than having the classic horseshoe shape
(so wealthy spectators in the seats high up
could enjoy the audience’s show as much
as what was happening on the stage, as well
as easily observe what other wealthy patrons
were getting up to), now every seat commonly
faced towards the stage and it became difficult
to see what members of the audience were doing.
Effectively, the audience ceased to be part
of the night’s entertainment.
As the show began to focus more on what was
happening on the stage, the cheap seats in
the pit began to be upgraded from simple wooden
benches to plush seats where the wealthy began
to sit so they could see the performers better.
When this happened, the cheap seats switched
to being up high and far away from the stage,
where the expensive seats used to be.
From this vantage point, it became much more
difficult to throw food at the performers,
and those wealthy patrons sitting near the
stage were less than enthusiastic about getting
hit by poorly aimed projectiles, helping to
morph the rules to this being no longer accepted
behavior in the theatre, though it has persist
somewhat in certain other venues.
For instance, throwing things on the stage
at pop music concerts is relatively common,
and even the Beatles once lamented that for
a little over a year period they were continually
hit on stage, first with soft Jelly Babies
in England and then in America with the much
harder Jelly Beans.
George stated of one particularly bad show
in Washington D.C.,
“…that night we were absolutely pelted
by the f*****g things…
To make matters worse, we were on a circular
stage, so they hit us from all sides.
Imagine waves of rock-hard little bullets
raining down on you from the sky… if Jelly
Beans traveling about 50 miles an hour through
the air hit you in the eye, you’re finished.
You’re blind, aren’t you?
We’ve never liked people throwing stuff
like that.
We don’t mind them throwing streamers, but
Jelly Beans are a bit dangerous, you see!
… Every now and again, one would hit a string
on my guitar and plonk off a bad note as I
was trying to play.”
In fact, the Beatles’ 1964 performance in
San Francisco had to be completely stopped
twice due to the barrage of Jelly Beans becoming
too intense, forcing them to retreat and implore
the audience to knock it off.
(For more on all this and how it started,
see: When the Beatles were Pelted with Jelly
Beans)
Beyond the occasional heckler at comedy shows,
sporting events are another venue that more
classic audience participation has endured.
For instance, in the early days of baseball,
players sprawled on the grass along each baseline
with the fans right behind them.
This provided fans with easy access to those
athletes…
Too easy.
If spectators didn’t like what was going
on, they could scream directly behind the
players and also weren’t opposed to chucking
objects at them.
Dugouts with walls and a roof, located below
ground, eventually were created, providing
much needed separation.
kitty_Burke-340x513In the 1930s, this type
of common audience interaction even led to
a fan batting during a Major League Baseball
game.
Audience member Kitty Burke, who’d been
incessantly heckling Joe “Ducky” Medwick,
eventually marched onto the field and grabbed
a bat, intending to show Medwick how it was
done.
Nobody objected and so pitcher Paul “Daffy”
Dean threw her a pitch, with Kitty swinging
and grounding out.
This made Kitty the only woman to bat during
an official Major League Baseball game.
While a fan trying this today would soon find
themselves the recipient of a night in the
Clink, the boisterous behavior of patrons
at many sporting events still often resembles
that of audiences through most of history.
But due to stricter rules and that the rowdier
members of the crowd are typically further
from the field of play, this doesn’t usually
disrupt the sporting spectacle, though the
athletes still have to endure non-stop taunting
or cheering (and the occasional projectile)
in many professional sports from fans at all
levels.
Of course, it is not uncommon to have a (often
inebriated) fan running onto the field of
play and being chased around by security.
Despite this interrupting the show the rest
of the audience paid to see, everyone tends
to cheer for the runner and find the whole
thing thoroughly enjoyable, particularly the
longer the fan on the field can manage to
evade capture…
We really haven’t changed that much
at all, it turns out.